[Music]
the nevada state athlete commission will
discuss the requirements
for future beneficiary events
after the death
of a uvi student last month how are you
greetings cristian cásseres with
on news now in spanish night
In Valencia, 20 years old, he died after
a boxing match organized by the
Sigma Capa fraternity with the
aim of raising money, according to the
emergency call to 911, the
paramedics were not on site
when Valencia collapsed in the ring.
to brain injuries
after police spent hours
trying to crack down on the case of a
man holed up in the northeast valley
on Sunday officers say a
man refused to cooperate and turn himself in to
neighbors said they heard gunshots
though it's not yet known if anyone
was killed  injured or what sparked
the shooting the suspect was taken into
custody about 10 hours later and was
eventually  the change of the
airport will take place they want me to the airport in
harry read officially there will be a
ceremony on tuesday to celebrate this
change the county commissioner approved
the new name in february however they
had to is since the money
used for that transaction was from
funds  The airport will keep
the name of the f as l to s and
now we will go to the tico weather phone. We
will have a partly cloudy day
with temperatures in the 50s there is a
chance of rain for Tuesday
this will attract a wave of wind and
we will continue with temperatures
below  60 degrees during the day I'm
Cristian Cásseres with his own
newscast the news now in Spanish good
day
[Music]